quand l'industrie à chercher à remplacer
les gras trans néfastes pour la santé
elle s'est tournée entre autres vers
l'huile de palme c'est ingrat qu'on
utilise de plus en plus dans l'industrie
alimentaire en raison de ses propriétés
d'être quasiment solide à température de
la pièce ne cherchez pas cette huile
telle qu'elle survive à lyon d'épicerie
vous ne la trouverez pas bien qu'elle
soit très présent dans les produits
transformés comme les biscuits
pâtisseries chocolats et condiments
l'huile de palme raffinée a été chauffée
et elle était désodoriser et décolorée
de sorte qu'on a du grand père cette
huile de palme et translucide contraste
avec la couleur orangée de l'huile
d'origine
[Musique]
on obtient l'huile de palme en pressant
la pulpe du fruit d'une variété de
pamiers qui pousse principalement en
indonésie ou en malaisie est un peu en
afrique l'huile est très prisé dans la
cuisine de tous les jours cette huile à
l'état naturel a des propriétés très
importante pour la population locale et
les riches entre autres en vitamine a et
1 manquent de cette vitamine peut mener
à la cécité
l'invité minaj un rôle important dans
l'immunité pour la croissance pour la
vision ce produit est la source la plus
riche des vitamines du règne végétal
mais ici au canada on n'a pas vraiment
carence en vitamine a non non on va la
chercher
en étant raffinée elle perd ses qualités
nutritionnelles et le problème c'est que
comme le beurre l'huile nature contient
50 % de gras saturés l'huile de palme
modifié et l'huile de palme hydrogénées
75 % de gras saturés et que dire de
l'huile de palmiste qui atteint la barre
des 80%
celle ci est obtenue en pressant le
noyau des fruits du palmier cette
question les acides gras saturés est
important et lis beaucoup plus peut-être
dans le pays où on a tendance à
consommer trop de grands et avoir
d'autres facteurs de risque de maladies
des maladies cardiovasculaires
même si certaines études récentes
suggèrent que les gras saturés d'origine
végétale sont moins dommageable que ceux
d'origine animale il faut quand même
surveiller la quantité qu'on absorbe
meiway ce grand classique de vache en
famille un gardien sucre du constructeur
lui même l'enrichir et la ville de perm
et de palmiste modifié huile de palmiste
hydrogénées et quand on regarde le
tableau de valeur nutritive si on se
retrouve avec en gras saturés avec 36 %
de la valeur quotidienne quand on mange
un gâteau énorme
autre exemple dans ce port conne au goût
de beurre le deuxième ingrédient et
l'huile de palme après les greens maïs
dans le nutella l'huile de palme est
aussi le deuxième ingrédient après le
sucre une cuillère à table contient 10%
de la valeur quotidienne en gras saturés
dans ce sac de bonbons avec l'huile de
palmiste hydrogénées on a non seulement
des gras saturés mais aussi des gras
trans
ces produits ont une valeur
nutritionnelle très très discutable et
on parle d'aliments électrodes
transformé pour ses produits industriels
qui ressemblait des aliments mais en
fait quand vous regardez la liste
d'ingrédients vous vous demandez ce sont
encore des avions en europe on trouve
beaucoup de produits sur lequel le
principal argument de vente et sans
huile de palme est d'abord un fait que
l'huile de palme a mauvaise presse parce
qu'on dira c'est très saturé c'est
mauvais pour la santé l'autre argument
si environnementale on parle beaucoup
des grandes plantations de paniers en
malaisie par exemple plantations en fait
qui détruisent les sols et qui déplace
les cultures vivrières pour
l'exportation on trouve l'huile de palme
non seulement en alimentation mais aussi
dans les cosmétiques et même dans les
bio carburants
on la jouait à paris arnaud gautier du
fonds mondial pour la nature le wwf qui
est une des organisations
internationales de conservation les plus
importantes la production est étirée
vers le aujourd'hui par une demande
croissante d'une part parce que la
population mondiale est croissante
nexity tout simplement pour nourrir la
population mais cette cette production
elle est aussi tiré vers le haut par des
usages dont on pourrait se passer
typiquement les agrocarburants les
bailleurs fioul on a plus de 50% des
moulins à huile de palme et il y en aura
plus finissent dans les réservoirs des
voitures pour faire du vieux diesel ou
des avions offert de kérosène ça c'est
une aberration absolue c'est certain que
les industriels utilisent beaucoup une
ville de vannes sénile la moins chère au
monde c'est aussi lui la plus productive
au monde
production à l'hectare delà des
plantations qui atteignent entre 4,5
parfois six tonnes de production d'huile
à l'hectare pour faire le parallèle si
vous cultiver du soja c maximum une
tonne d'huile à l'hectare c'est pour
cette raison que le wwf et même d'autres
ong comme greenpeace
n'ont jamais appelé au boycott pur et
dur de l'île de man s'il fallait
remplacer tous ses volumes pas
l'équivalent en huile de soja en huile
de tournesol en huile de colza il nous
faudrait six fois plus de surface
devant le tollé provoqué par la
destruction de la biodiversité
l'industrie alimentaire se tourner vers
de l'huile de palme certifiée durable
la certification rsp où est la plus
reconnue actuellement la
balle molle et 2004 cette certification
elle a évolué dernièrement et elle va de
plus en plus vers une protection de
l'ensemble des forêts il n'en reste pas
moins que la production d'huile de palme
donc le panier à ville contribue à la
déforestation petit contribuer à la
déforestation puisqu'on à une demande
croissante au niveau mondial certains
grands utilisateurs comme unilever
cadbury kraft nestlé ou ferrero le
fabricant de nutella disent vouloir
s'approvisionner uniquement d'huile de
palme certifiée durable
le problème c'est qu'en 2021
80% de l'huile de palme produite
mondialement ne l'était pas certains ont
réussi d'autres ont diminué leur
utilisation en remplaçant l'huile de
palme
on voit beaucoup de produits où ça a été
remplacé par du beurre de karité donc
des huiles exotiques ou de l'huile de
coco et l'huile de coco c'est l'huile
qui a le plus d'impact environnemental
pour la production au niveau mondial
nous continuons à produire de l'huile de
palme c'est déjà déforester mais surtout
arrêtons de déforester de nouvelles
forêts de couper de nouvelles forêts
pour planter du bagne amis nous comme
consommateur qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
le plus simple c'est de cibler le label
8 obame durable et respect c'est le plus
évident c'est un amalgame plein de
défauts mais pour le moment si ce qu'il
ya de plus robuste et de plus simple sur
le marché
la certification rspo s'applique à
l'ensemble de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
c'est à dire plantations fournisseurs
fabricants de produits alimentaires
malheureusement on ne la voit que très
peu car les fabricants ont rarement
intérêt à mettre de l'avant la présence
d'huile de palme dans leurs produits
[Musique]